first up there are three candidates in
this race only one of them take positive
rating with people Bernie Sanders is
right
burny burny burny all right
what is your tour bus like I so now
you're in California obviously because
the primary is coming up this is the
biggest state I always say we should get
a lot more representation in the Senate
than we then we do think you should have
more senators than Vermont exactly
that's where I was going with that ah
but we'll leave that for another day but
what would it say to the Democratic
establishment if you were to win and the
polls are about even now with you and
Secretary Clinton what would it say if
you were to win in the biggest date I
would think that it would say to the
establishment that the people are sick
and tired of establishment politics and
economics and they want real change in
this country and and if we can fill if
we can win here in California I think we
got a good shot to do that and if we can
win in many of the other states that are
coming up on June 7th we will go into
the Democratic convention with a great
deal of momentum that's what it says
well I think you'll also go in with
after this email report came out this
week a little more than momentum now you
famously said in one of the first
debates with Hillary Clinton no I'm
tired of hearing about the emails and
you know for a long time I was tired of
hearing about the emails and I still
don't think she committed some horrible
crime but that story has moved a little
bit has it not it has but this is what I
also think there is enormous frustration
on the part of the American people with
way we do politics in this country and
when most politicians though they are
gray you're terrible vote from the other
guys the scum of the earth blah blah
blah blah but you know what people are
hurting in this country you know a
middle class is disappearing we got a
lot of poverty we don't have health care
for all people people want us to talk
about their lives and their issues and
not just spend our whole lives attacking
our opponents and
and we were we were teased with
something that was going to be an
amazing show I thought earlier this week
which was a Bernie Sanders Donald Trump
debate nut was bruited about hmm what I
would have loved oh I know and let me
just let me just say that mr. macho
chickened out
Donald was gonna go first he said he
would do it then he said he wouldn't do
it then he said he would do it and he
said he wouldn't do it
so I would hope that if he changed his
mind four times in two days
change it a fifth time you know Trump
claims to be a real tough guy pushes
people around hey Donald come on up
let's have a debate about the future of
America
yeah I mean I think a lot of us and I
cut myself who have supported you even
if you're not the nominee we would like
to see what a clear choice would look
like no I would like it in the election
but we - the election I would at least
like to see it in a debate because when
you see the Republicans debate among
themselves which is all we've seen so
far they live in the bubble okay where
global warming doesn't exist and where
President Obama doesn't exist
oh he exists he exists then they have
spent eight years trying to obstruct
everything that he has tried to do right
but okay so I think you about 46% of the
devoted delegates at this point okay so
very very close but you are always in
polls winning against Donald Trump where
Hillary Clinton now is either tied or
losing if those polls got to a point
where Hillary was maybe ten points
behind it all Trump what I'm trying to
get to is what is the tipping point in
your mind where delegates would actually
go oh you know what because they want a
winner they want to win they want a
winner where they would say you know
what we are backing the wrong horse well
here's the weird thing about this
process
400 or more super-delegates actually
supported Hillary Clinton came out
publicly before anybody else was in the
race before the first ballot was cast
and I think your point is a good point a
lot has happened since that point and
what every person at the Democratic
convention wants to do is to make sure
that Donald Trump never becomes
president of the United States of
America and I think you know and I think
your point this is an interesting point
these delegates even if they have
supported Clinton from day one they're
going to have to take a hard look and
say look if Bernie Sanders is beating
Trump in many instances by double digits
not only in national polls but in many
state polls I think we're 17 points
ahead of them here in California if
that's true and if there are states
where Clinton is actually losing
to trump where bernie is winning
shouldn't we make sure that the
Democratic nominee defeats Donald Trump
and that is the issue that they're gonna
have to deal with yeah I what I don't
understand about this race is that on
the Republican side it seems to be okay
to say well Donald Trump as much as we
may think he's a crazy person
well that and I do I'm gonna let me yeah
let me just say no idea I mean this is
not just of a lot of Republican
colleagues and friends so I disagree
with they're not crazy they're honest
people right this guy is a pathological
liar yeah and again I don't mean to be
malicious but that is just the damn
truth right and he would be a not only
an embarrassment a real danger to this
entire world if he would have become
president
well that's that's coming from someone
he calls crazy Bernie so what and I've
been trying to get this answer out of
everybody who comes on the show what is
the right strategy to run against Donald
Trump because obviously Hillary Clinton
doesn't have it what would be your
strategy that is a good question and I
would not be honest if I told you that I
figured it out yet because he is so
unpredictable because he lies all of the
time because he changes not a joke
right because he changes his mind all
the time but he said yesterday is no
longer a valid today how do you deal
with that and more importantly he's not
held to count it like that as other
politicians absolutely let's just Donald
Trump who changed his mind right
watching times in a day so it is not it
is not easy
III think for us thought probably one of
the effective approaches against them is
to really point out to what I think most
Americans understand is that we are
proud a deep down of our diversity the
fact that people come from all over the
world become Americans and contribute to
our country and some of the meri Donald
Trump
and I honestly think that the that the
vast majority the American people are
not happy with these vicious attacks on
Mexicans and Latinos right and Muslims
in women that's one way I think you can
make the case against them
the other thing also he is primarily a
showman he is a very good manipulator of
the media but the truth is he has no
ideas on public policy and the ideas
that he has are absurd right giving
hundreds of billions of dollars of tax
breaks to the top two-tenths of one
percent not particularly good public
policy but you know that if he runs
against you the big word is going to be
socialized them at the risk of annoying
you because I talked about this with you
before I'm going to take another run at
this socialism it's not a bad word to
your crowd it's so funny there's such a
generational divide in this election the
people under 40 next to Adderall they
love you the most
because
they don't they don't even remember the
Soviet Union and capitalism has not
really worked for them and you know you
are not a socialist in the sense that
everything has to be socialist you're
like every other modern intelligent
country in this world
quasi socialist capitalism works for
most things but some things should be
off-limits to the profit most likely
health care like raisins I would say
covering them elections elections
themselves so can't we just make that
case that can weaken sure we can look
number one I mean I don't the greed of
Wall Street in corporate America is such
that there is now a profound anger
against the top one-tenth of 1% who
appear to want at all and could care
less about the middle class of this
country but the second point that you're
making is that I think most Americans
understand that in the year 2016 it is
not a radical idea to say that public
colleges and universities should be
tuition free that the wealthy and large
corporations should start paying their
fair gate universities used that's
exactly right it's not like we're doing
something that new no yeah that's right
we're going back to where we what fifty
years ago right is it is it a radical
idea to say that the United States
should join the rest of the
industrialized world every other country
and guarantee health care all of our
people as a right I don't think so
is it a radical is a radical is it a
radical idea to say that we should not
have a corrupt campaign finance system
in which billionaires buy elections I
don't think so so your point is is well
taken
look entrepreneurialship etc creates a
lot of good things in this country and a
lot of wealth but the American people
are entitled to know that they're gonna
have health care education
decent housing the basic needs of life
should be there for all of our people
Bernie Sanders everybody
thank you so much
get it he don't even
go